pendant sa colle et celle ci oui oui tac
tac tac tac tac coller mais aussi taillé
me les agences et le travail de la
mosaïque demande minutie et
concentration pour ces néophytes ce qui
est le plus difficile c'est la courbe et
les angles sarah l'enseignante fait
débuter ses élèves sur un canevas de
type antique mais elle compte rapidement
leur faire travailler d'autres
techniques et d'autres matériaux comme
le marbre
le but leur faire fabriquer des
mosaïques en volume en mélangeant les
matières bref des créations
contemporaines
il ya des choses vous allez canton port
n qui sont qui se font et à beaucoup
d'artistes et voilà donc cet atelier va
pouvoir promouvoir un petit peu cet art
façon contemporaine aussi j'espère à
l'origine de ces cours l'association 3r
si elle est connue pour les rencontres
internationales de la mosaïque
c'est la première fois qu'elle propose
ses ateliers au grand public
après avoir reçu beaucoup de demandes
votre activité autour de la mosaïque
elle est partie depuis 92 sur
l'insertion des personnes en difficulté
par l'intermédiaire d'un travail de
mosaïques et on n'avait pas développé ce
ces cours vis-à-vis du grand public mais
ça nous a quand même interpellé
et on a on a souhaité répondre à la
demande moi ça fait longtemps que
j'attendais l'atelier parce que je suis
passionné mosaïque depuis très longtemps
j'avais déjà fait un stage en province
et quand j'ai vu que ça ouvrait je me
suis précipitée l'association réfléchit
déjà à développer des cours du soir et
des stages pour enfants